thank you i'm jim breyer i'm a venture
capitalist with axial partners in palo
alto and i've been on the board of
facebook and investor in facebook for
about five years what's your next
investment well we we have about a dozen
investments in social media companies
around the world and Julia and for any
other panels that might be interested
what can we as either business investors
or part of the business community around
social media do better to further many
of these causes that we've talked about
today I'm going to talk to you
afterwards one-on-one because I need
your advice I mean absolutely i was i
was talking with someone just the other
day about how he uses mobile phones to
get medicines into villages and able to
predict supply and demand in a much much
clearer way and having been out in
Africa knowing that the growing use of
that sort of technology is absolutely
crucial I mean imagine if this network
as we said before taking things to scale
imagine if we can do that through
empowering community leaders to you know
even if it's someone saying I know that
there's a cutting ceremony that's due to
take place within two months and then
being able to gear up around that I
think there's so much that can be done
and and the empowerment around that is
huge but also what I found through my
experience is how many people have
contacted me globally so this is not
just about what the West can do I had so
many emails from people in cameroon in
Guinea in all sorts of placing what can
I do in my own community and one thought
is just about you know there's not one
database for example that's someone
contacted me from Guinea Bissau to say
can i download from the web I'm about to
teach this class what can i download
from the web I couldn't find a sinkhole
place where that person could just go to
be able to say to their community these
are the
issues that you could deal with so we
need to hit this straight on